Kurdish fighters retreating from the so
called safe zone but Turkey says his
patrols will determine if the withdrawal
was in line with the deal is signed with
Russia last week the safe zone is a 440
kilometer long and 32 kilometer deep
area that stretches from July Lewis
Northwest to Mauna Kea on the border
with Iraq east turkey has insisted on
establishing a buffer zone on the border
with Syria saying it's crucial to
prevent the people's protection unit the
YPG from expanding its influence Turkish
authorities consider the YPG a terrorist
group for the u.s. though the YPG the
main Kurdish faction in the Syrian
democratic forces or SDR was a crucial
ally in defeating ISIL the retreat of
the Kurdish fighters would be a crucial
moment for President Recep Tayyip
Erdogan who has been warning against a
full-blown military confrontation if
Syrian Kurdish fighters remain in the
safe zone
alderman bill killer tartan de rusha
Azzam now has given the information to
our relevant authorities that terrorists
organizations have completely withdrawn
it was a tense day a mortar landed near
a Russian military personnel in the
Basia on the border with Turkey Russia
and Turkey carry out joint patrols in
those areas clashes erupted between the
turkey back Syrian National Army the
opposition armed group and the SDF on
the outskirts of Vienna Risa mm [ __ ] in
the meantime as the SDF fighters pull
out Syrian government troops are
redeploying taking over more territory
near Missoula and Bashar in diversity
our redeployment will continue until we
reach the Iraqi border God willing we
will rescue people from the Turkish
invasion and terrorist groups but on the
ground its Russia and Turkey that have
the upper hand they support rival groups
in Syria but managed over the last few
years to set aside their differences and
broker a deal to end the Syrian conflict
Turkey wants to establish observation
post in the safe zone warning that any
push by the Syrian government or the SDF
to move to the area will be met by force
Hashima para al Jazeera Gaziantep on
Turkey's border with Syria